are you done now you've completed the
third season yeah third season is is out
it's funny it's like it you know it's so
there's so many things out it's so
crazy I mean we put it out last
month and then I think people are just
kind of finding it like I said like like
people come to me like hey did it come
out yet I'm like yeah yeah I came out
last month it's like it's like three
graded teeth I ended my late night show
um like a year and a couple of months
ago
so it's been almost like a year and a
half since that since I ended my like
whatever almost 30 years in late night
and all the time people come up to on
the street and go like man I love your
show it's you know you're killing it and
I'll be like you know I don't do it
anymore I I do a lot of other things but
I I don't do that and they they I mean I
swear to God I've had people say to me
like man every night I'm watching it and
I'm just loving it and I think it's just
hard for there's no awareness I don't
know it actually it's very humbling but
there's so much content out there and I
think what's happened is it's very hard
for I I have a philosophy that good work
is never wasted yes and I believe that
if you make something good it's the
Field of Dreams idea if you build it
they they come yes and by keeping your
head down and doing your good work we
live in this world now the flip side of
there's so much out there is that things
don't go away no it's always going to be
there and there are shows I watch
um that I think have probably been off
the air for like 15 years that I did
find when they were first on and or
Morgan about you know what's the
government in Denmark and I'm like I'm
watching this show and I really like it
and I'm like this great this new show is
fantastic so that shows from 2009
yeah I don't know no I mean
someone's starting breaking bad this
morning yeah you know like yeah someone
is watching it for the first time right
they're home and they're like I kind of
keep hearing about this thing and I
think in this career too and you're such
a great example of it I think it's just
like it's a lifelong thing and it's and
it's you just keep doing it and you just
keep you know because you keep growing
from it and hopefully you keep getting
better at it yeah and that's the that's
that's the inspiring part is could I get
better at this could I do it differently
um it's a different world now with
different technology that's been a huge
thrill of this podcast is I you know
this was a total Lark and yeah I love
these conversations more than the
conversations I had you know for almost
30 years on late night I loved those
they're very different and they're
performative but these mean a lot more
to me in some way because it's a real
connection if you if we're talking on a
late night show
I will not get this no sense of you oh
my God you know what I mean I would have
loved to do the couch on your show but
it that never happened as it was ending
and I was kind of just getting into a
position to be able to do that stuff but
this is so much more like you know you
don't even sometimes you don't even see
anyone backstage it's like it's so fast
like to get to sit and hang for an hour
and
yeah that like like you can really smell
me right now like you smell what I smell
like yeah and that never happened we had
all kinds of fans and deodorizers on The
Late Night show but now you're smelling
my musk I would say that's the biggest
difference you know seeing you is you
realize yeah your show is such a
deodorized version of you
like like on TV and I think Sandalwood
it was it was that's what the all those
years I was on NBC or TBS it was a
sandalwood hints of uh of cinnamon and
then this is just me this is who I am
and what I smell like so you're gonna
have to deal with it it's beautiful I
think it's raw you know I think I think
it's uh it's special you know well my
only request I'm gonna wrap this up is
first of all so cool getting to talk to
you no seriously uh you're a lovely
fellow you're so talented and I really
do like your work so my hat's off too
and I'm not wearing a hat why did I do
that no one even knows what I'm wearing
so you could have been wearing a hat I'm
wearing a Willy Wonka top hat and I'm
tipping it to you right now and that
takes a lot of finger strength it does
it's a big hat it's a 35 pound hat uh
it's made of copper and iron very cool
having you here and I want you to keep
doing your thing you know and we're
gonna hang I know we're gonna hang I
love that and my only request is that
you figure out an organic way to work me
into the show of course a very tall
Irish Catholic guy but I have to play
Conan O'Brien oh okay it's not an acting
part you have to be it's got to be one
of those jump the shark episodes okay
where Romney bumps into Conan O'Brien
and brings him to the mosque
and I keep looking into camera and
saying like well this is gonna be you
know this is going to be an interesting
turn of events you know what I'm saying
you know and uh you know yeah last time
I saw a rug that big I was at a wig
store I am looking right into the camera
I mean I'm gonna get a real tone lecture
from my father but I'll do it
I'll do it you'll be like why I'll do it
your thing was going so well we raised
you for tonal consistency
and then you pull this Conan I'm
sorry Dad it's the episode where Rami
jumps the shark completely
look who I found I bring him to the
diner it's Conan O'Brien hi guys looks
right into camera and hello out there
audience
why did he do that he broke the
fourth wall
he didn't seem to understand much about
the religion or the culture maybe I'll
just end at season three